des tables des rendez vous en tête à
tête mais ne vous y trompez pas il ne
s'agit pas d'un speed dating amoureux
mais de rencontres professionnelles
c'est le concept du sky business day
pour la deuxième année consécutive cette
convention d'affaires réunis grands
groupes pme et tpe
en tout 600 entreprises ont investi le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
tout le monde parle d'emploi d'emploi
mais il y aura plus d'emplois si vous
augmentez l'activité économique de nos
entreprises donc c'est ce que l'on fait
en démultipliant leurs prospects donc
leurs clients vous augmenter leur
activité économique et donc bien sûr
l'emploi
ces deux entreprises basées sur notre
territoire ne se connaissaient pas l'une
est spécialisée en prises de vue
aériennes la deuxième propose des
loisirs connectés dans les milieux
aquatiques 25 minutes plus tard
l'entretien s'est révélé fructueux
dès le début d'année c'est effectivement
se revoir pour le préciser effectivement
quel type d'événement va pouvoir prévoir
à mettre en place pour le printemps été
2010 huit nouveautés de cette édition
2010 est le village de l'innovation 10
start up implantée à saint quentin en
yvelines ont été sélectionnés pour
mettre en avant leurs innovations parmi
elles taken by un service de commande et
de livraison qui verra prochainement le
jour et qui a pu multiplier les contacts
lors de l'événement on a rencontré la
banque populaire
on a parlé des financements c'est très
important pour une start up
il ya un effet de levier qui est
important pour nous pour qu'on puisse
développer notre notre solution et le
groupe hôtelier en europe hôtelier
justement on aimerait connaître leurs
besoins en matière de livraison les
entreprises de saint quentin en yvelines
vont d'ailleurs pouvoir mieux se
connaître grâce à la sky business map
présentés lors de l'événement un outil
interactif qui permet de découvrir
l'ensemble de l'écosystème territoriales